die scharia in deutschen schulen ja sie
haben richtig gehört das ist eine schock
studie die uns auf wird eine studie die
schlimme zustände an berliner schulen
offen legt im bezirk neukölln
islamistische schüler die dort ihre
klassenkameraden bedrohen die ihre
regeln dort durchsetzen auch gegenüber
lehrerinnen etwa wenn die sommerkleider
tragen statt kopftuch schon rein in
diese studie in einige typische anonym
gehaltene zitate aus dieser studie dass
hier das berichtet zum beispiel eine
lehrerin
sie sagt ich als türkische frau kann im
sommer nichts mit einem kurzen kleid auf
der straße laufen ich muss allen ernstes
darauf achten was ich als hier ja oder
eine schulleiterin die das hier erzählt
sie sagt in dieser studie und dann will
man israel aus dem atlas herausschneiden
und übermalen das kommt immer mal wieder
vor sagt sie an einer anderen schule
drohte der sohn einer syrischen
flüchtlingsfamilie der lehrerin also in
der schule haben sie das sagen und ab
dem schultor habe ich das sagen und
meine gang ja oder hort leiterin die da
in diesem papier berichtet über kinder
nur araber dürfen beim fußball mit
spielen das ist das was man auch öfter
auf der straße hört hier in berlin in
den bezirken was denkt man jetzt über
diese studie wo sich das alles abspielen
soll unser kollege hans harwig hat sich
hier in berlin am kottbusser tor und vor
dem rathaus neukölln umgehört
[Musik]
ich höre dass sowas an der
bushaltestelle meistens guck mal wie die
wieder angezogen hat guck mal wie sie
mit dem kopf doch warum leute die eine
zigeunerin oder sowas so sehr viel halt
warum hast du nicht
zweimal hat der private gründe
zuckerkranke oder so diabetes man kann
ja nicht immer dann fassten aber habe
ich schon etwas in der schule erlebt bei
uns ist es nicht an der schule also ist
mir nicht bekannt auch mobbing allgemein
ist nicht bei uns an der schule begann
meine kinder
aus
dem bereich seien schon noch nicht
mitteilen dass ein schüler seinen
schülerinnen und ein lehrer zu einem
lehrer seinen schülern ganz mexiko an ja
also eine in aber die ist nicht in
meiner klasse und die wird immer von
anderen auch gemobbt sie wird halt
ausgeschlossen nur weil sie kein
kopftuch trägt und von anderen die
kopftuch tragen und so ist ja ihre
entscheidung auch na ja ich glaube also
jeder sollte den glauben des anderen
respektieren so wie es in den
grundgesetzen auch drinnen steht ich bin
selber auf einer schule gegangen wo wir
drei vier deutsche waren und das andere
waren alle nationalitäten
wir wohnen nicht gezwungen ramadan zu
feiern die wohl nicht gezwungen
weihnachten zu feiern obwohl sie ja
weihnachten feiern irgendwie aber ja
also bei und bei mir war alles friedlich
in der schulzeit also irgendwann hoffe
ich dass es wieder so wird
darüber wollen wir sprechen mit dem
mitglied des berliner abgeordnetenhauses
von der fdp ist und zugeschaltet
fräßdorf große herzlich
eine deutsche jetzt immer da ganz genaue
frist auch wenn wir über eine deutsche
schule hier in berlin sprechen in diesem
fall im bezirk neukölln an der eine
lehrerin an gemacht wird weil sie kein
kopftuch trägt weiß dass die berliner
politik dass es so etwas gibt
das schlimme daran ist dass die berliner
politik ist schon seit vielen jahren
weiß dass es diese zustände an berliner
schulen gibt und dass wir zu wenig
getan haben schulen soll und tempel der
bildung seiner nicht tempel irgendeines
gottes und mobbing und insbesondere
religiöse mobbing haben überhaupt keinen
platz an den berliner schulen müsse
konsequent dagegen vorgegangen werden
das ist leider in den letzten jahren
nicht passiert das heißt ganz konkret
weil es wurde in den letzten jahren
gemacht um aufzuklären um religiösen
mobbing vorzubeugen und auch was muss
geschehen wenn man da offenbar bisher
keinen schwerpunkt gesetzt hat ja was
geschehen muss ist dass wir konsequent
jeden einzelnen modelle fallen wenn in
der schule nannten das dagegen vorgang
und dass die aufklärungsarbeit leisten
religion ist privatsache und gehört bei
uns private und nicht in die schule und
hier muss einen gesetzes verständnis an
den schulen erreicht werden auch bei den
schülerinnen und schülern es kann nicht
sein dass kinder während des ramadans
zum fasten gezwungen werden oder
mädchen gemobbt werden weil sie kein
kopftuch tragen hier muss die schule
gleich bei den ersten vorfällen
einschreiten da muss mit projektwochen
gegengesteuert werden man muss aber auch
darüber nachdenken mit
disziplinarmaßnahmen gegen einzelne
schüler die das mobbing intensiv
betreiben vorzugehen und die sind auch
mal gegebenenfalls an eine andere schule
zu geben um ihr in scharen einzugreifen
es war bisher zu wenig wir müssen das
stärker handeln wir haben eine neue
bildungs naturen die aus einer
neuköllner grundschule kommt die diebe
kennen müsste wir erwarten von mir dass
ich hier jetzt konsequent auch gegen
dieses religiöse morgen an den schulen
in berlin vor und ok disziplinarische
maßnahmen gegen die dann tatsächlich
aktiv nutzen aber das scheint ja eine
ganze kultur zu sein die da in manchen
schulen zumindest in manchen klassen
gelebt wird wo deutsche wo unsere
grundwerte möglicherweise in der
deutlich in der minderzahl sind
mittlerweile also das schafft man das
nicht mit einzelnen
disziplinarischen maßnahmen was ist da
die große lösung was muss die neue
bürgermeisterin frau gefeiert da
anpacken ich glaube klar muss sein dass
fundament unseres zusammenlebens das
grundgesetz ist und nicht die bibel
nicht der koran hat sondern das
grundgesetz regelt unsere zusammenleben
und ist tolerant das demokratische
grundgesetz und dieser geist muss auch
in den schulen vorher schon dass es mir
ziemlich egal woher die schülerinnen und
schüler kommen solange es eine studie
leute ist gelten die werte eben und das
grundgesetz so wir müssen die in den
schulen durchsetzen und wenn die kultur
in den schulen abgedriftet ist dann ist
es auch ein fehler der letzten jahre
dass man das vielleicht aus falsch
verstandener toleranz hat gewähren
lassen man muss gleich zu beginn einer
solchen entwicklung gegen arbeiten das
heißt ich muss mit projektwochen liegen
staatenlos verständnis schaffen ich muss
diese werte von anfang an vermitteln das
bringt in der grundschule an setzt sich
in den oberschulen vor das heißt aber
auch
weil man eben nicht gleich am anfang
angefangen hat das heißt aber auch dass
es zu spät ist was jetzt ich denke nicht
dass es zu spät ich denke man kann
gegensteuern aber es ist halt ein sehr
intensiver prozess die man jetzt starten
muss das wird nicht von heute auf morgen
passieren können das muss eine mischung
sein aus diejenigen die das treiben muss
sich auch mal aus der gemeinschaft
rausnehmen wo anders hinsetzen und muss
die schulgemeinschaft verbrennt
mitnehmen und ihnen die werte vermitteln
die uns alle doch eins und das ist das
entscheidende dass wir es schaffen
dieses demokratieverständnis dass
toleranz verständnis welches wir in
deutschland und berlin haben und die
grundlagen des zusammenlebens ist dass
wir dieses vermittelt bekommen an den
schulen und das eine große aufgabe
verlieren und lehrer weil es nämlich
viel mehr für den abfall einfach nur
inhalte in den fächern zu vermitteln
sondern hier geht es um werte um ein
gemeinschaftsgefühl das die gesamte
schule jeweils gefragt einen geist zu
schaffen der das aber das ist ja auch
eine herausforderung für lehrerinnen und
lehrer bei der sie begleitet werden
müssen das muss ja irgendwie auch mal
umgesetzt werden wir müssen ja irgendwie
auch mal anfangen neu zu denken und zu
sagen vielleicht brauchen wir neue
schulfächer die toleranz lernen
miteinander lernen also wo es in der
schule nicht nur auf das ist die bibel
das ist der koran und so weiter und so
fort sondern wo wir eben genau das
fördern aber diese konkreten vorschläge
so scheint es mir die kommen ja gar
nicht aus der politik ja es ist ein
gewisses aufgaben über die wir reden ich
weiß gar nicht ob wir zusätzliche fläche
brauchen wenn ich höre dass wir im
erdkundeunterricht fälle haben die
schülerinnen und schüler sagen wir
müssen israel von der landkarte tilgen
dann muss ich da sofort gegenhalten und
muss dann auch einen exkurs machen zu
dem thema und das thema aufarbeiten und
das kann ich dann in anderen fächern
aufgreifen und fortsetzen ich glaube
dass uns zusätzliche fächer da nicht
unbedingt helfen werden sondern es muss
eigentlich in jedem fach sich
durchziehen wie ein roter faden das
unser demokratisches und tolerantes
verständnis in jeder schule in berlin zu
gelten hat und da brauche ich eine
fläche sollen auch eine haltung die sich
dem entgegen stellt also nachdem corona
hat check in der schule zum grundgesetz
check danke an paul fräßdorf aus dem
berliner abgeordnetenhaus
vielen dank